bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les quark les particules
élémentaires sont les plus petits
constituants de la matière elles ne
peuvent pas être divisés en des objets
plus petits
elles sont à la base de tout ce que l'on
connaît des structures les plus
microscopique aux plus grandes galaxies
les quark sont justement une catégorie
de particules élémentaires
il en existe six types différents
les quarks up down charm strange top et
bottom les quark présente principalement
trois caractéristiques intéressantes
tout d'abord leur masse certains des
quarks sont lourds et d'autres plus
légers les quarks up & down sont les
plus légers de tous il nécessite donc
relativement peu d'énergie pour être
créés et ils sont très stables
pour cette raison ils sont les croire
que les plus communs dans l'univers en
s'associant par groupes de trois les
quarks up & down forme notamment les
protons et les neutrons qui sont à la
base de tous les atomes
en termes de masse viennent ensuite les
quarks charm et strange qui sont
plusieurs dizaines de fois plus lourd
enfin les quark top et bottom sont les
plus lourdes tous avec en particulier le
quark top qui est plus de 70 mille fois
plus massif que le hub à cause de leur
masse très importante
ces quatre quark sont beaucoup plus
rares que les quarks up & down
il nécessite une énorme quantité
d'énergie pour être créés et sont très
instables n'en trouve donc
principalement que dans les
collisionneur de particules où ils sont
créé volontairement aux moyens de
réaction très énergétiques dans le but
de les étudier
[Musique]
la deuxième caractéristique intéressante
des quarks et leurs charges électriques
dans l'univers toutes les autres
particules élémentaires possède des
charges électriques entière qui peuvent
valoir soit 0 aucune charge soit 1 une
charge positive soit -1 une charge
négative mais dans le cas des quark
ces derniers possèdent une charge
électrique qu'on dit fractionnaire c'est
à dire qu'elle ne correspond qu'à une
fraction de charge entière
les quarks up charm et hop ne porte en
effet que deux tiers d'une charge
positive et les quarks down strange et
bottom ne porte qu'un seul tiers de
charge négative
cette caractéristique très singulière de
ne posséder qu'une fraction de charges
rend les quarks uniques en leur genre au
sein des particules élémentaires
[Musique]
cela dit bien que les quarks à eux tout
seuls ne possède que des fractions de
charge
ils vont toujours se regrouper à
plusieurs de sorte à former des
assemblages dont la charge électrique
totale elle est belle et bien entière
dans le cas du proton par exemple qui
est formé de deux quarks up et un quark
down les différentes fractions de
charges que portent les trois quark
s'additionnent pour former au total une
charge entière positive dans le cas du
neutron ce sont deux quarks down est un
corps cup qui vont se compenser pour
former une charge totale nul dans notre
univers
il existe pour chaque particule
élémentaire une sorte de particules
jumelles qui possède la même masse une
charge électrique opposé
c'est ce qu'on appelle les
antiparticules ils sont à la base de
l'antimatière
les quarks n'échapperont pas à cette
règle il existe donc également six
antiquarks dont la charge électrique est
opposée par rapport aux quark standard
dans la nature pour les trouve le plus
souvent en couple avec leur quark
respectifs formant ainsi des assemblages
dont la charge électrique totale nuls
[Musique]
enfin mis à part leur masse et leur
charge électrique
la caractéristique la plus intrigante
des quarks et ce qu'on appelle leur
charge de couleurs la charge de couleurs
est un autre type de charge que
possèdent tous les quark contrairement à
la charge électrique qui existe sous
deux formes positives et négatives
la charge de couleur existe sous trois
formes différentes que les physiciens
ans baptisé rouge vert et bleu
ces charges de couleurs n'ont absolument
rien à voir avec la notion habituel de
couleurs ces termes rouge vert et bleu
ne sont que des noms qui ont été
choisies de façon arbitraire pour
désigner les trois charges dont
l'univers chaque quark possède une
charge de couleur soie rouge soit vers
soi bleus les antilles quark quant à eux
possèdent les charges opposées anti
rouges anti vert et antibes le tout
comme la charge électrique
si l'on regroupe plusieurs quark
ensemble leurs différentes charges de
couleurs vont s'additionner
si l'on regroupe notamment un quark
rouge un quark vert et un quark bleus
l'ensemble aura une charge totale de
couleur blanche c'est-à-dire ne t'en de
même si l'on regroupe un quark avec un
anti quark de couleur opposée par
exemple rouge et anti rouge
le couple aura également une charge
totale de couleur blanche dans la nature
les quarks vont toujours se regrouper
pour former des assemblages dont la
charge totale est de couleur blanche
par exemple dans le cas du proton les
trois quark qui le composent doivent
impérativement être rouge vert et bleu
de sorte à ce que la charge totale du
proton soie blanche il en va de même
pour le neutron ou pour les couples
quark antiquarks
autre particularité étonnante de la
charge de couleur celle ci peut changer
au cours du temps imaginons par exemple
un quark de charges rouge à cause de
phénomènes quantiques complexe il est
probable que soudainement le quark
change de couleur et de vienne par
exemple bleus en devenant bleus le quark
a perdu sa charge rouge
celle ci va alors s'échapper sous la
forme d'une toute nouvelle particule qui
quitte le quark ce qu'on appelle un
gluant le bouillon emporte avec lui la
charge rouge ainsi qu'une charge anti
bleus pour compenser la charge bleus qui
vient d'apparaître chez le quark dans le
cas général un lion porte toujours une
charge de couleur standard rouge verte
ou bleue ainsi qu'une anti charge anti
rouges anti verte ou anti bleus
imaginons qu aux alentours se trouve un
deuxième quark qu'il lui est déjà bleu
s'il parvient à recevoir ce guillon
il va alors l'absorber ce qui va le
faire changer de couleur à son tour en
particulier il va perdre sa charge bleu
des s'approprier la charge rouge du lion
au cours du processus
tout se passe comme si le quark rouges
avaient échangé sa couleur avec le quark
bleus dans l'univers ces échanges de
guillon sont très fréquents ils et quark
sont constamment en train d'interroger
leurs couleurs cette interaction à
distance permet de maintenir les quarks
entre eux
un peu comme s'ils étaient reliés par un
élastique si on essaye d'éloigner l'inde
et quark alors à cause de phénomènes
complexes
les quarks vont se mettre à s'attirer et
ce de plus en plus fort un peu comme
l'élastique qui devient de plus en plus
tendue lorsqu'on essaye de les tirer
on appelle cet effet très puissant
l'interaction forte
c'est une des quatre interactions
fondamentales à la base de l'univers
l'interaction forte s'assure de
maintenir les quarks entre eux
permettant par exemple la cohésion des
protons et de neutrons pour finir une
conséquence importante de l'interaction
forte et qu'il est expérimentalement
impossible d'observer un quark tout seul
pour comprendre
imaginons par exemple que l'on décide
d'isoler l'un des trois quark qui
forment un proton lorsqu'on tire sur ce
quark pour le séparer des autres
l'attraction devient de plus en plus
forte mais si l'on tire assez fort sur
le quark
il est tout de même possible de le faire
sortir du proton cependant au moment où
l'on parvient à l'isoler tout se passe
comme si l'on avait brisé l'élastique
qui le rattachent et aux autres quark
l'énergie de la liaison est alors
subitement libéré et elle va se
convertir en matière formant de la sorte
un tout nouveau couple quark antiquarks
au final on a bien réussi à retirer le
quark du proton mais celui ci n'est
toujours pas seul car il est désormais
lié avec un anti quark ce phénomène qui
empêche les quarks d'exister de façon
solitaire est appelée confinement de
couleurs il a pour conséquence de
maintenir les protons et les neutrons
liés entre eux assurant ainsi la
cohésion des noyaux d'atomes et
permettant donc de stabiliser toute la
matière qui composent l'univers
[Musique]